when you're training somebody
what signs does somebody give you to say
this guy is potentially a guy that could
be
a guy at that level and at that level i
mean these guys have made it at the
highest level of a game it's not like
they're not the
they're the cream of the crop yeah so
you're talking about whoever is in the
nba today
they're they're they're a hollywood
celebrity on the back you know high
school campus
everyone on college campus knows them
then you're going to nba like oh [ __ ]
i'm a
bench warmer i'm coming up and it's all
start then it's this then it's that
what what signs do you see um
where you say this guy's different
there's something about this guy that's
there's something about her that's
different what are those signs they see
that he said there's a very
distinct difference between this guy and
that guy he's just as talented
she's just as talented but there's
something very weird and different about
his personality
what are some of those things he just
if you just pay attention to the details
you pay attention to the details
you could those distinguish those
distinctions are easy
are easy to see all right everybody
talks about working
working hard showing up early showing up
late doing all
everybody can do that everybody can do
that
it's the mannerisms of the way they
carry themselves it's the way they
compete
it's the way they listen it's the way
they absorb infra
information how coachable they are the
one thing
all my athletes
in business in sports
the best of the best are so coachable
they're they listen
they listen they absorb the information
they pay attention
they're there they're willing they want
that information and they know the
difference between
false information and information that
can actually
work for them you know kobe had a uh
with the first interview
they did um with kobe when they said oh
yeah
you're uh you hired tim grover you hired
mj guy you know
uh what do you think about him he goes
he ain't done [ __ ] for me yet i don't
know
he's like yeah he did great things for
mj and he's done great things for other
things
he ain't done nothing for me i don't
know setting the tone
right there how did you process that
when you heard that
oh i just i i wouldn't expect anything
else i didn't do anything for him yeah
i didn't do anything and too many people
look at the history of what they've done
in the past they look at their past wins
their past
their past successes these individuals
they've
always want they you could when you look
at that competitive
person you can always see with kobe i
saw it very early
when the in the um playoffs
in against utah when he shot all those
air balls
at that you know he was about 17 and
always came in the league at 70. so he
was like 18 or 19 when he did that
but for most individuals that would have
just totally killed their confidence
how is he how did he come back how did
he handle it did he run from the
adversity did he
run from the media what did he do no he
came back and owned what he did
and says i'm coming back i'm coming back
for more i'm coming back for more
for mj it was just never forgetting
that he got cut from the varsity team
when he tried out as a sophomore
and there's another story that you know
people don't know uh
a few people know this so he goes
everyone told him don't go to north
carolina
so he says no i'm going because you're
never going to play you're not going to
be you're going to be on the bet you're
going to be on the bench
so he goes to north carolina and i'm
pretty sure
um buzz peterson
was the number one ranked player
in high school that year and he also
went to north carolina
so dean smith comes in and they make
some roommates and he
and dean dean was like he goes michael i
want you to meet uh
i want you to meet uh bus peterson bus
peterson is the number one
ranked player last year in high school
as a number one recruit and michael
first thing goes to dean he goes he
never played me
how could he be number one now let me
ask you when dean did that did he
know jordan's wiring or he did not just
oh he so he did already
so dean know how to poke yes okay that's
it and he's just just trying to
just trying to see because he wanted to
say okay
i know what this kid has now
how i just laid something out for him
first day of practice let's see where he
let's see where he let's see where he
takes it all right and then michael's
response
how can he never played me how could he
be how could he be number one
and now people say things now are they
actually going to do it
the one thing all these individuals had
after each
championship while everybody was
celebrating
they would come and give me a hug and
say
what's next
what's next
because they're like you can't we can't
come back the same
if we come back the same
winning isn't going to winning is no
longer going to greet us
you know i have a thing in the in the
book where
the bus the bus takes you to the arena
right it has it it says where it's going
you get on that bus you win the
championship
and then when you get back on that same
bus after you've won the championship
the sign has changed it doesn't say the
destination to the hotel
it says this bus ride is back to hell
because if you're not willing to take
that ride this will be your last win
you know every single successful person
every single one that you
that you've had every single win
the next one's a little bit more
difficult it's a little bit harder to
get
you become more smarter you become more
educated you know
you know more but you can't come back
you cannot
come back the same individual especially
when you're trying to repeat
at something that you've already won
at so to win the first oscar to win that
second
it was anthony hopkins it was 85
85. i don't know when he won the one
before that
possible
but you those things are just they're so
and those are things you look for in
individuals it's just like you know what
can
what can it what can i see in um
game six after jazz
uh no this was uh this was uh with kobe
game six uh they lost to boston
all right and they're having he's ha
they're having dinner
and you know i i've never worked for the
organization so there's certain things
that i
i have to say i had to stay away from so
he's sitting there and he's having
dinners with with the coaches and the
team and then he's ha
different individuals and then you know
i get a text to say come on down
and he's sitting down called me now
we're having this conversation
and this is this is already you remember
he's already won three championships so
this was
this was going this was going for not
number for this was going for number
four
and he's going he sits there and he has
his conversation with me and he goes
man i hit him with everything with the
kitchen sink
and i looked at him i said when the hell
are you saving the sink for
and he just gave me that mama glare he
just
i said how many times do people go
through in life
what a thing to say back to the guy why
you that's crazy to say that
did he did his reaction to you get
pissed at you or was his reaction like
you're
right what's his reaction i could he
didn't have to say a word
okay he didn't have to we were so in
tuned he didn't have to say a word got
it when a minute i saw that look
he knew i knew exactly he knew what was
he what do you think guy
was he what do you think i or no meaning
like if something's happened to the game
hey uh
tim what do you think about the the game
i played today no so
no he so he would want the information
but the thing is
we would only discuss
that i saw that could have meant could
have been done better but these guys
are so in tune to what they do before
you even point out they already like i
already know
i already know because their obligation
to themselves is so much greater than
anybody else's obligation to them
and they they understand the difference
between criticism and feedback they know
what the difference between
they know the difference between the two
and basically the difference between the
two is how you hear it
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye